how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we got a lot of news about the MCU
and about Avengers endgame including
everything that has happened in the last
11 years leading up to Avengers in game
as well as what is to come after
including character deaths and Avengers
in game I'll break it all down in this
video quick reminder about my giveaway
I'm giving away 5 imax tickets so if
you'd like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is be subscribed
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
so the Avengers issue of Empire Magazine
comes out on March 21st however we have
learned that in this issue there's an
interview with Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige and in this interview Kevin
Feige has officially named the first 11
years of the MCU leading up to Avengers
in game the Infinity Saga this is the
perfect title seen as how the Infinity
stones have been present in the MCU
since all the way back to Captain
America at the First Avenger
of course the tests are activating the
space stone but as we get closer to
Avengers in game we get closer to the
end of the Infinity Saga and according
to Kevin Feige and some of the writers
for Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame we can expect some of the
storylines and characters to come to a
definitive ending after Avengers in game
here's what Kevin Feige had to say in
the interview with Empire Magazine we
wanted to bring to a conclusion a series
of movies in a way that had never been
done before Harry Potter had an ending
because there were only so many books
Lord of the Rings 2
[Music]
but we thought 22 movies in wouldn't it
be fun to bring some finality to the
storyline so the president of Marvel
Studios has already said that there is
going to be a finality to some of the
storylines and the writers are also
starting to tease this here's what one
of the writers had to say in an
interview the MCU continues to exist who
happens to be in it is fluid and
evolving because it's all connected you
can't reboot one all the parts have to
work together things continue but like
life losses are real and change is real
Avengers endgame doesn't do what you
think it does it's a different movie
than you think it is also the deaths are
very real I just want to let you know
that it's real and the sooner that you
accept that the sooner you will be able
to move on to the next stage of grief
with Infinity Ward we broke your hearts
now we're going to blow your mind so
based on what the president of Marvel
Studios has said and what some of the
writers have said it certainly does seem
like we're going to see the end of some
of our heroes storylines are definitely
going to be ending but the way they talk
about deaths makes it seem like we are
going to lose some heroes especially
since we know that some of the main
Avengers contracts are up and the
directors the Russo brothers have
stressed that the consequences and
sacrifices in these movies are very real
so it seems like Avengers in game really
is going to blow our minds but really
could be the end for some of our heroes
it is definitely going to end some
storylines and the deaths of those
characters could be what ends these
storylines obviously the two main
characters most speculated to die are
Captain America and Iron Man so let me
know what you think about this news and
let me know if you think some of the
main Avengers are going to die and if so
which ones you think are going to bite
the dust leave your thoughts in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Avengers in game and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]